da würde ich bin wie der helfer ist eine
gute geschichte anleitungen gibt die von
mir gemacht haben die auf jeden fall
auch im zweifel frei und ihre reputation
haben
hey leute bevor du dir durchgeht noch
zwei kurze sachen der sache das kleine
mädchen im letzten video bade haben sich
jede sorgen gemacht dass die eventuell
irgendwelche negativen reaktionen ab
bekommt deswegen noch mal der aufruf
teilte die irgendwie aus dem
persönlichen leben kennt richtigen
lieben gruß von mir aus seid wirklich
lieb lieb lieb zu ihr und macht ihr
keine bösen kommentar oder im wasser und
an zweiter stelle leute ich möchte
einfach mal hier aufrufen dass hier
alles in die kommentare schreibt was
euch in letzter zeit an einem kanal
gestört hat mich die positiven dinge
einfach alles was ich gestört hat könnte
er doch kurz überlegen und dann einfach
alles reinschreiben egal was du bist
egal ob meine frisur ist meine
einblendungen mein auto meine augen nur
erwarb alles was rein wer das macht kann
ich meine videos verbessern damit und
vielen dank dafür ich war für den video
zum neuen video heute spielen wir mit
massig werden willkommen was ja heute
mache ich bin hin wenn du deine show von
max die daheim abbonieren löschen oder
video auf wäre alles rund um youtube
über drei frechen entweder auf e mail
abonnieren
den manche deutschland mit dem möchten
wir aufnehmen und sie habe leute andrej
arschawin und willig gedroht ich würde
eigentlich damit werden drei verdreht
bitten geht carlo die lobby und yankow
[Gelächter]
michael pachter alter ich muss mich
jetzt habt ihr mehr kein gut auch musik
schneiden auf jeden fall wird dann
irgendwann kuckelbeck gezeigt aber egal
ob opel kann echt gut auf motiv scheint
trotzdem mutig da ich muss mir einfach
löschen oder wöchentlich er die lenkung
ist schon längst da wäre etwa die lok
ist oder miguel partner
wer auf mehr abonnieren können dann
würde ich im ersten partner abonnieren
und mit dem noch nicht aufnehmen ich
spüre jetzt bist du wirklich zu
konvertieren exportchancen global change
und mal waren wir flogen park hinein
sprechen mal meine kämpfe habe ich
keinen videos geschaut hab ich ihr
gesicht das heißt so ein bisschen marie
meinberg monaten mit ihrem neuen kelly
und marie mal bei persischer wert katie
oder lokal abonnieren davon noch erklärt
auch wenn ich möchte nicht mehr so gern
mag die früher irgendwie aufnehmen wird
dann wahrscheinlich eher noch mit long
polen damit hätte dann zur folge dass
ich mal eine löschen würde aber so ist
es halt manchmal auch ich liebe alles
klar allerdings die fortis geregelter
tacho led kay mittel wieder
damit machst du nicht diese und dann
noch mit
ich kenne mich persönlich kennt
das ist wie experiment von leiche
irgendwie über eine million
ich weiß nicht mehr wer älter ist und
die wir dann erfolgen wenn der tag
erwischt und natürlich würde achtung
jetzt abonnieren aw led hochgenommen
werden ich würde mit einer löschen weil
das klingt für mich zu seiner ex manager
und ich würde mich gerne ein video
aufnehmen wie wird das video in guten
morgen hin
für michael warteten angepasst tv seinen
der ju und ladenflächen seien wegen der
nach wie vor so ein bisschen cancer von
youtube deutschland ist bei craft
aufnehmen würde ich mit ihm aufnehmen
will scheint mit allplan ich finde seine
video eigentlich ganz nett muss ich
sagen also ich gucke nicht regelmäßig
aber ich bin ganz nett ich würde 1000
prozentig mit unter 20 aufnehmen
einfach weil ich für diese stuttgarter
gehring mehr feiern aber es geht erst
recht wir ebenfalls erklärt er ich habe
sogar schon mit unserem partner
aufgenommen also doch damit regel und
unsympathisch furious kanal irgendwas
minecraft mäßiges aufgenommen
[Musik]
abonieren unsympathisch könnte ich mir
gleich ganz gut gegen einen mieter für
mich auch und rabbani alles gut dann
wenigsten gerne juliane schenk und
direkt
[Musik]
das war auch drei youtuber die
persönlich nicht durchschaue okay ich
wünsche euch am ersten single löschen
eine gestellte portugal keine ahnung
wird die art des bistums zu erwirken
also müssen wir auch betrifft studien
mit den berner aufnehmen und stefan
gehrig abonnieren
du bist terrorist ali karimi nächsten
drei sexy money david okay da gebieten
sandy habe ich kennengelernt und er ist
echt nett also täglich der der schon am
längsten von irgendwelchen klischees und
vorurteilen und sowas verfolgt wird auf
youtube deutschen weil er halt einfach
mit am längsten dabei ist aber die
sympathischer kerl da wird es schon
nicht gelöscht ich find die hat mehr so
die ideen sage ich mein neues
logischerweise hingeht auch keine kraft
und ideen aber so im hinblick auf
youtube hatte schon einen guten plan und
jetzt habe ich einen löschen kg berlin
aufnehmen würde ich dann mit dem a-team
abonnieren
du bist du die perle will ich wirklich
aber ich würde einfach dem etikett
abonnieren
warum wobei dann erhält für quality für
schritt plate und von einem video gibt's
das projektorchester bin ich 33 diesen
drei jonas ems und die garnituren geburt
gary länger zeit wird auf jeden fall
gerry weber zu abonnieren auf jeden fall
gewährte um ihre arbeit wichtig einfach
wie ich leben würde
da würde ich menschen lieben video
veröffentlichte von allen guten geistern
zu lassen weil bei mir gute geschichte
erläuterungen gibt die von mir gemacht
haben die auf jeden fall auch eine
zweifelsfreie positive reputation haben
auf jeden fall und ich würde
wahrscheinlich schon nach interview von
ehemals jubelt ich habe beweise
vorliegen dafür und mitstudent etwas
aufgenommen und motiviert nämlich
schlecht gefühlt und wie viel gesehen
dass mirka zufügten dem doch noch
hoffnungen
schön dass welchem kraft über 1000 tiere
bekommt kraft gibt es noch menschen die
noch schlimmer für die nächsten drei für
mich macht man damit durch gewannen die
letzten shows und ok davon kenntnis und
kristallinen davon so richtig aber egal
du musst aber den namen gehen
der gipfel eine sache der sehr gut ist
im john oder angie ist der gute arbeit
ich habe das schon gut ja genau das weiß
ich genau so gut denn er kommt von
schauen wer hat er kein gut andere
kanäle zeigen das heißt mit dem würde
ich aufnehme mich halt gut weil er mit
gut pushen würde löschen würde ich den
der nicht fest
abonieren würde ich dann auf jeden fall
okay alles klar ich habe keine
übertragung könnt ihr was damit anfangen
ich kenne mich wartet auch einfach
überhaupt nicht kein anderer wichtigsten
alles klar dass auch seine video hier
oben könnte meinen kanal abonnieren hier
unten führen eher zufällig ist altes
video maschine verlegt in diesem raum
nach oben zu sein